you may have already heard that the
pandemic recovery in many parts of the
world is warping global supply chains
the latest evidence container ships are
backing up at ports worldwide a global
surge in demand has put more ships
underway
more than on the ground labor and
downstream logistics can handle
another factor the continuing log jam
from the evergrip ever given that's the
ship that got stuck in the suez canal in
march
now take a look at this the number of
containers held in europe's largest port
rotterdam rose by nine percent in the
first half of 2021 compared to the
previous year now the somewhat smaller
ports of antwerp and hamburg have also
seen significant backlogs rise
now the delay in processing is causing
headaches for importers and shippers
alike and it means that shipping prices
are rising and the containers have
become harder to find
now for more on this we go to our
financial correspondent chelsea delaney
in frankfurt chelsea we just had a quick
look there at the container backlog
itself what it means for the ports what
they're seeing what about the latest
industrial data aren't we already seeing
some signs of this kind of backlog and
what it's doing to europe's economy
definitely this has been a very
data-heavy week for the european economy
and to be perfectly frank it's all been
quite disappointing um just one example
we saw industrial orders which is
important because it shows how busy
factories are going to be
in the coming months those were down
about eight percent so these supply
chain issues are becoming more serious
and we've sort of entered this new stage
where a lot of different issues are
converging so you have not just things
like a semiconductor shortage that we've
seen all year we're also now seeing
natural gas and broader energy shortages
we're seeing
these shortages of commodities like
steel and wheat in lumber and to add on
top of that now we've got congestion at
european ports so all of this raises the
risk that we get this toxic mix of both
inflation from these constraints and
lower production and economic growth
chelsea what does this mean downstream
from these ports as we look at the
retailers who are so dependent on
getting these products what does it mean
for christmas
yeah i hate to be the grinch here but it
does look like it's going to be a bit of
a difficult christmas especially for for
shoppers and consumers we are hearing
more and more from retailers from
supermarkets that that they're having
trouble getting products and that we
could see shortages we've heard this
from supermarkets here in germany over
the past couple of days they say
things like pasta or potatoes or meat
could be in short supply quite quickly
as well there are a lot of goods that
are still stuck in asia so toys
electronics all of these
things that people might be wanting to
buy in the christmas season
it's possible that they may not get here
in time so some big retailers are
looking at other options they're looking
at flying goods over they're looking at
moving production to other facilities
for example closer to them and in latin
america
but this is something that's going to
last a long time and we likely will see
less supply and more expensive goods in
this winter
all right dw financial correspondent
chelsea delaney in frankfort thank you
very much
all right chelsea touched on this a
little bit but with ports tied up why
can't companies just ship over land
well many are trying to do just that and
now demand for truck drivers is rising
quickly now it's a problem that's
especially pronounced in the uk
but it's hitting continental europe as
well
yaroslav fennec has been driving trucks
for 15 years
not an easy job
there's a lot of stress all the time
lots of traffic many people don't behave
very nicely
you lose a lot of time at work and we
work every day 12 13 and sometimes 15
hours
based in belgium he hauls freight all
over europe
demand for workers like him has gone up
over the years and so have the
challenges he faces
many things have to change firstly
parking
then we have a tachograph which records
driving time and the fines are very high
if we break the rules if i don't find a
place to sleep my driving time goes up
and that's a big problem
across the channel in the uk a massive
shortage of drivers has been straining
supply chains the pandemic and brexit
caused many eu drivers to leave
to try and lure them back uk prime
minister boris johnson promised special
visas initially valid till christmas now
extended to next march
dutch trade unionist edwin atema says
that's not nearly enough actually
they're laughing like do they really
think that we quit our eu job to help
the uk until christmas eve yeah that's
short-term solution and which is no
solution a veteran trucker himself atema
is critical of the industry in the uk
but also the eu where large sections of
the trade rely on cheap labor from
eastern europe
in western europe european laws are not
enforced which allows that workers are
exploited these exploited workers fill
up the gaps in the supply chain which
cannot be happened
in the uk in a moment
some fear that down the line continental
europe may also end up with gaps that
cannot be filled even trucking companies
with better working conditions already
struggle to recruit we got trucks we got
trailers we got jobs
but we don't find the drivers
with shortness of drivers
the prices will be higher because
everybody wants to be served and then
the risk is that equality will fall down
britain's crisis could lead to improved
working conditions for drivers there
salaries have already gone up but
yaroslav fennick thinks it will take
more than that to draw eu drivers back
the offer would have to be super extra
mega good to make it interesting
and at least for the moment
it is not
[Music]
all right lars griner is associate
partner at hamburg port consulting he
joins me now for more on these supply
shortages that we're seeing these
logistic challenges lars good to have
you on the show we just saw a piece
about shortages in truck drivers there
uh part of that is the pandemic part of
that appears to be how many people were
in the pipeline to have training as a
truck driver you work at the port to the
hamburg port your port supports your
main focus what is the hold up there
that you guys are seeing where is the
the the pinch point for what you're
seeing there
i i i think in general it it it's you
could almost say it's almost like the
perfect storm um yes the the pandemic
has the pandemic sorry has been a a
catalyst for issues and problems that
were developing already and what we see
now is it's catalyzed a lot of issues um
four m four main issues but a whole lot
of issues at the same time
um it's catalyzed the fact that you know
container flows were because when the
volumes were down people were able the
lines were able to control the container
flows a bit better so we've now we've
now got
we've now got container imbalances have
come back in which weren't there um
it's it's
the ports have have we're always
teetering on the on the edge of
congestion we've now we've now seen a
lot of
um congestion in in the major ports
particularly in the united states and
starting in china again
um
and that and that's led to a reduced
number of vessels being available at the
same time during the pandemic the a lot
of owners took the chance to refurbish
vessels or even take some older vessels
out of service so at the moment we've
got fewer vessels on the market that
they would than they would have been at
the beginning of covert and then finally
and then finally the pandemic has has
really just changed the flow of goods
um you know people are buying a lot more
online now people are looking at
different things to what they were
buying before um there's a lot more
consumer goods being bought as
when people can't travel so these have
all added to it to a problem that was
there already
what does that mean for what does that
mean for companies what does it mean for
the companies themselves what kind of
delays are they seeing
in in terms of delays i couldn't give
you firm firm numbers at the moment um
you know it it it's again the pandemic
is still causing fluctuations you know
you've seen the situation in in vietnam
where factories were closed for i think
was seven weeks and a few factors remain
open with people staying there um but
their production is just down as well uh
i couldn't really give you numbers of of
what it means for them but what it means
they need to re-look at their supply
chain um
how they're producing and
how they will produce into the future um
but doing that in a market where they're
not assured where they're not sure what
the future really is at the moment
uh lars briefly one of the things
real quick
is when will this get better do you have
any idea briefly if you could
to be honest there's no real short-term
solution for this um you speak to
most people and they say this is going
to go well into 2022
potentially into 2023.
there are so many factors at the moment
that could determine it i think what
we're really seeing is which we're
seeing the changing of the supply chain
to a more digitalized supply chain and i
think the solution coming back to your
truck drivers again um the the one of
the reasons why there are less truck
drivers available is everyone's waiting
for the movement towards automation in
that regard so it's not an attractive
commit um career with with a real future
in it
so i think what
what we're going to see now is we're
going to see
the push towards a more digitalized
economy and only when we see that really
starting to come in or we see some
relief starting to happen and we'll have
to leave it there lars griner with
hamburg port consulting thank you as
always
pleasure thank you very much have a good
day
you